la situation à la frontière entre la
biélorussie et la pologne un sujet
évoqué tout à l'heure par vladimir
poutine devant le collège de la
diplomatie
russe mais le président s'est également
exprimée à propos d'autres de ces
épineux la correspondance à moscou
devait rahman crise des migrants
afghanistan ils craignent les tensions
avec le temps les états unis veulent a
dit mr poutine a fait le tour des sujets
brûlants lors de son intervention à la
réunion du collège du ministère russe
des affaires étrangères
un des premiers sujets abordés par le
président russe a été la clis délit
grand la frontière polono biélorusse
pour la dit mi-août ils l'occident se
sert de cette crise pour faire de la
pression sur la biélorussie tout en
oubliant ses engagements humanitaires
les pays occidentaux utilisent lac la
crise migratoire à la frontière polono
biélorusse pour susciter des tensions
supplémentaires dans cette région est
exercé des pressions sur
minsk et notamment sur le plan
humanitaire
regardons aujourd'hui comment les
services de sécurité polonais se
comporte à la frontière on le voit très
bien la télévision sur internet
pauvres petits enfants qui sont là
les aspergent d'eau de gaz
et la nuit des hélicoptères volent le
long de la frontière des sirènes sont
branchés la dmr poutine a affirmé que la
russie devait obtenir des garanties pour
sa sécurité à long terme le président
russe a également souligné que la
réduction des tensions politico
militaire répond non seulement aux
intérêts russes mais aussi aux intérêts
de toute l'europe et du monde entier
écouter aujourd'hui cette bonne
coopération qu'il y avait entre l'ue et
la russie
aujourd'hui se sont nettement dégradées
et
lieu continue à
pratiquer la langue de des sanctions et
cela se ressent sur les plans économique
mais aussi sociaux et culturels il faut
que bousaid comprennent bien que la
baisse de la tension
ici c'est pas seulement les intérêts de
la russie mais c'est l'intérêt de tous
les pays d'europe à la fin de son
intervention le président russe a
reconnu que le fardeau était lourd pour
le service diplomatique russe qui
travaillent dans des conditions très
difficiles il faut également noter que
c'est la première fois que vladimir
poutine s'exprime devant le collège du
ministère russe des affaires étrangères